[Music]
over the past year nobody has dominated
first-person shooters on Twitch more
than shroud shroud was the most watched
FPS streamer this year and for good
reason
the former counter-strike pro is a
shooter Dodd among streamers terrorizing
players in every FPS he touches I made
in the background on a platform where
controversies in drama runs rampant
shroud boasts a squeaky-clean record
which makes him an easy sell to sponsors
just got at Walmart and I bought like 12
cans of madrenas even though I get that
[ __ ] for fridge won't let you guys know
like shroud could have pushed to become
the face of twitch if he really wanted
to but the dude said [ __ ] that and
joined mixer instead hey might yeah what
should do you it I make a move and he
misses you oh hi busy
now looking back at shrouds last couple
of months on Twitch we can see a slight
dip in viewership but that decline was
not due to waning popularity or his
skills declining trout was just playing
whatever he wanted and at the time that
just happened to be while classic Myrtle
allows doing your viewership really I
basically in my mind's eye figured I
would not get the views I normally get I
would not get the dose I usually get I
would not get the subs I usually get I'm
playing this game for my own thing
shroud was less concerned with what game
got him the most viewership and instead
he focused on what game he wanted to
play but in his first official mixer
stream shroud returned two shooters
playing the new Call of Duty for almost
80,000 people who tuned in are you ready
yes
no way now shroud was late to streamed
and when he did show up viewers were
treated to the usual he was in his room
ready to ruin someone's day and call of
duty I'm just going back and forth with
his window in that balcony try to farm
I'm kind of far from XP with this good
because
much better than my hat this was a lot
different than ninjas first mixer stream
which was held live at law Palooza in
his very own ninja dojo with an audience
behind him shroud spent the first hour
waiting for COD to launch only to spend
the next hour trying to connect to the
game's overloaded servers it's doing
this on Xbox too honestly this is kind
of what I expected I don't know why I
expected anything different
watching shroud is like watching your
friend play games except this friend
just happens to be a god at any shooter
that he touches I'm telling you boys
this gun will be sick just give me a
give me a little bit to warm it up and
then I'll talk about it well ninja might
have been the first person to switch
over to mixer shroud might be a bigger
draw for personality is looking to
switch platforms let's be real for a
second shrouds not the global gaming
icon that ninja is see ninjas the only
pro streamer to really break into the
mainstream but shroud is definitely one
of the world's biggest streamers I mean
hell before they both moved to mixer
shroud was pulling in more numbers than
ninja was if guys like X Q C and T
fousey shroud doing well on mixer they
might also jump ship because let's face
it having the freedom to play whatever
you want because you have a guaranteed
paycheck waiting for you it's pretty
tempting obviously you know mixer got
ninja they got shroud and who knows
who's next bro so the question is what's
next for shroud well looking at ninjas
time and mixer it's likely that shroud
we'll see a dip and viewership compared
to his time on Twitch on mixer ninja
averages around 15,000 viewers per
stream which is lower than the 41,000
average viewers he had on Twitch the
month before he left
right now shrouds crazy viewership has
helped out by the free subs mixer is
giving out to his channel but once this
promotion ends shrouds average viewers
will probably decline now this lower
viewership is kind of expected since
twitch has a [ __ ] ton more viewers than
mixer does right now they probably have
maybe a total forty to fifty thousand
concurrent viewers across the entire
platform right now currently on twitch
right now currently across the entire
platform concurrent 1.5 million
concurrent viewers reality check those
they're not doing anything for the
platform you can't pay for a community
you can't buy viewership it won't matter
if shroud doesn't become the
most-watched streamer in the immediate
future because with Microsoft and his
sponsors backing him shroud has the
opportunity to become something more
than just a streamer thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up art Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages